this is a nickel and Cobalt battery
popular in electric vehicles in the U.S
and Europe and this is a Lithium-Ion
phosphate battery also known as an lfp
battery Which is popular in China it has
a shorter range but it's cheaper to make
less prone to fires and lasts longer
both of these batteries were made by
catl a Chinese company that's the
world's largest ev battery maker of the
10 biggest EV battery companies six are
Chinese China is the dominant force in
EV battery production while the US is
deeply reliant on foreign batteries the
US and China are now David and Goliath
situation when it comes to battery
production we're comparing how the US
and China stack up in the four main
stages of battery production from Vinyl
assembly all the way back to sourcing
the raw materials
China assembles more than two-thirds of
the world's electric vehicle battery
cells U.S automakers lag far behind
several companies have outlined plans to
build plants in the U.S but shifting
battery production is difficult
Panasonic a Tesla partner learned this
when it started building a battery plant
at Tesla's gigafactory in Nevada
Panasonic found it couldn't just import
equipment from Asia different safety
regulations and different operating
conditions made it a challenge it also
had to train workers to make batteries a
finicky process where small mistakes can
have major consequences after years of
its joint battery business operating in
the red Tesla and Panasonic's cell
production has become profitable and
it's now a model for other automakers to
follow other companies have found
getting EV battery factories up and
running takes longer than they expect
toward the end of the supply chain is
where the US definitely seems like it
can make the most inroads and then try
to work its way back to traditional
Mining and processing from there it's
the earlier parts of the supply chain
that are more difficult before you can
make finished battery cells you need to
build all the components that make it
work the anodes cathodes separators and
electrolyte China is the global leader
in producing these components the US is
far behind we're talking about working
with very specific chemicals and
materials and turning them into vital
products so there's a lot of safety
testing and everything has to be very
carefully done so that's another reason
China having years of leadership in this
space is so critical because they have
the know-how they're able to adjust to
new technologies and they've been doing
this for a really long time both of
those together make it a really
Herculean task for the US to catch up
the U.S government has invested billions
in companies that are trying to do this
domestically but companies can need
years to develop the technology and ramp
up manufacturing automakers accustomed
to slower development Cycles are trying
to revise battery development strategies
in response to changing mineral prices
and Technology
for example companies have two main
choices when it comes to cathodes the
battery cells most expensive component
nickel and Cobalt used widely in the US
and Europe or lfp common in China U.S
companies have historically preferred
nickel and Cobalt batteries for their
long range but volatile mineral prices
have led some automakers to turn to lfp
batteries while these batteries can't
travel as far between charges they
typically last longer and have better
thermal stability meaning they're more
resistant to heat some U.S automakers
are particularly interested in them for
entry-level Vehicles iron phosphate is
in Vogue now but companies are really
investing in Next Generation batteries
as well companies are always innovating
and trying to change battery chemistries
that's why getting a glimpse of the
supply chain now and how it might change
is really challenging before you can
make components like cathodes and anodes
you need to process and separate the raw
materials that make them up the US
currently does little of this while
China is is the world leader and
companies often have trouble building
chemical processing facilities in the
U.S the bureaucracy here between local
state and federal regulations and then
rules all of that is a messy process
that will take time to work through and
a lot of resources then you have local
opposition oftentimes to these
facilities if there are concerns about
consuming huge amounts of water or
energy or even damaging the local
environment and the last big one is just
labor and supply chain issues like we've
seen throughout the coronavirus pandemic
and then there's the matter of getting
the raw materials most of the minerals
in electric vehicle batteries aren't
mined in the U.S or China they're
imported from countries like Australia
Indonesia and Congo China has strong
relationships with these countries where
it can get raw materials the US is
building new minds domestically and also
building International Partnerships but
both approaches have challenges it can
take up to a decade or more to get new
minds up and running in the U.S
Andromeda materials are only useful once
they can be processed U.S companies are
also trying to go to other countries and
say look we'll develop a mine here in a
country like Ghana or in Africa and then
we'll ship that material to the U.S to
be processed the challenge is a lot more
difficult to do even the processing
facilities in the U.S
in the U.S it's really difficult to get
new mines built and permitted because
there's a lot of environmental
opposition and people just generally
don't like mines in their backyard some
companies though are focused on an
alternative source of materials instead
of mining new materials they're
salvaging minerals from scraps and dead
batteries in the United States right now
we have some lithium
but really no nickel no Cobalt and on
grand scheme relative to all the lithium
that we're going to need we don't have
that much Ascend elements is a U.S
startup focused on producing engineered
EV battery materials it currently
operates a recycling facility in Georgia
and is building a larger one in Kentucky
that may cost up to 1.5 billion dollars
the company says it can produce enough
cathode precursor and active materials
to equip 250 000 EVS per year recycling
startups are among the more promising
American Battery materials suppliers but
they're far from matching the output of
factor trees in China the world's
largest battery recycler and their years
from contributing a meaningful amount of
material to the market the recycled
materials look exactly like a cathode
material made from Virgin material which
is you know mind material send it to a
third-party lab or whatever you couldn't
distinguish between the two Ascend
elements takes used batteries discharges
them and shreds them to recover the
critical components like lithium nickel
and Cobalt while separating out
materials like copper aluminum and
plastic they call the remaining powdery
material Black Mass through this process
Ascend says it recycles up to 98 of the
critical battery materials and does it
with a significantly smaller carbon
footprint than Mining and traditional
cathode manufacturing methods it's
currently focused on making nickel
manganese Cobalt cathode precursors and
active materials recycling may not
enable the US to outpace Chinese
production but it could still be an
important part of its domestic supply
chain the question isn't really whether
the U.S can catch up to China it
probably can't ever catch up really at
this point given how far ahead China is
but it will take many years for this to
play out a realistic goal is to just
clean up the U.S supply chain so there
is some domestic production of all these
critical components right now they're
just basically at the mercy of China and
these other countries this is much more
about security of basic Supply so that
battery shortages don't become a pinch
point in the energy transition
foreign